Imogen yes where are we going we're
going to Austria to marry Simon what
come on what happened to not too severe
and the flames at down no no I hope
we'll happy not there
[Music]
so I'm back in the office but I'm not
gonna talk about work at all today I'm
going to cover the weekends work
tomorrow what I'm going to do today is
give you some background information
some backstory seek and understand quite
what's gonna happen tonight
point number one on November 5th 1605
something happened called the Gunpowder
Plot
this was a time in the UK when the
control of the country was flipping
between Catholic and Protestant and you
know that can happen over a few hundred
years but this was one incident where a
group of conspirators were gonna blow up
the houses of parliament they had placed
barrels of gunpowder underneath the
House of Lords and they were gonna
detonate them on I think it was the
first day of Parliament and it didn't
work
this might sound familiar by the way if
you've seen the film or read D for
Vendetta it's kind of based off that
that's where the whole anonymous face
mask comes from because the guy who is
discovered hey the guy who is the
scabbard with the kegs of gunpowder it
was called Guy Fawkes because it was
1605 he was tortured and executed and
you know the whole thing kind of blew
over but this led to point number 2
which is Guy Fawkes Day every year in
the UK and I think in some ex colonies
there's an event where you celebrate
this failed attempt on the houses of
parliament it's kind of a weird thing
actually celebrate a failed attempt on
something any way you celebrate in the
same way that people celebrated back in
1605 which was apparently - like
bonfires and just set off these huge
huge fires and all over London and it
just sort of became an annual tradition
I think it was to begin with quite
anti-catholic thinks everyone was like
yeah over the years that's kind of
simmered down and I think more of the
attention has been put on Guy Fawkes
because in addition to bonfires and
you're so now getting fireworks you'll
have a burning effigies of Guy Fawkes I
guess you know 400 years later we still
still had to hold a grudge but these
aren't the only traditions some of them
particularly the older ones are very
weird and I'm going to somewhere tonight
which celebrates one of these and it's
unique because point number three is ah
two recent Mary
okay this house is kind of amazing it's
like how would you describe this house
you go amazing it's like mix all the
centuries it's better than Simon let's
not get carried away
most things are better than Simon none
of us have met this lady before and she
is Imogen and she not has not only fed
us wonderfully and invite us into her
home this is amazing she must be
in my actual glasses like these it's
like icicles and bosses on the end so
believe it or not we're here tonight
we're here because of the which is known
as the everything I say within okay can
you do that so Tom and I are in the car
we're about to go in two or three how
would you describe this evening so far
definitely surreal would be the first
it's been strange already I mean haven't
even got to the part where men are
literally on fire all my taking home
there's something going on in the
distance over there already oh yeah so
this is a massive event for the town
and there are thousands of people here
it's a relatively small town it's like
5,000 people to live here but it doesn't
feel like that at the moment we're just
gonna get some cash Simon we're going
the wrong way
oh yes
[Music]
like budget Star Wars
[Music]
[Applause]
we're on the rides this is all the
sacrifices this is gonna be fine it's
going fine
my name's Nick
Shane upset underneath
admit her up it's fine it's fine
[Music]
Oh
I was
[Music]
[Music]
okay so we're about to see the writing
of one of ours we think it's um it's
pretty crowded if we turn around this
way
[Music]
it should be a superfood
[Music]
people
I can't emphasize enough just how
strange this is there's like a massive
crowd of people and there's a huge fire
right in the middle bit and no one seems
to be worried right no one in this
situation taking pictures of this fire
[Music]
[Applause]
children do it with little balls
starting from one accord facts to this
lovely lady here so we just watched the
ignition of one barrel and it goes off
right it was just kind of carried off
the path it's like a relay and they're
not so much passed to one another the
local people basically rattle each other
for the barrel it's cry its pride on you
to actually be able to like receive it's
not it's only people donated for
generations that does it and then they
have to wrestle each other for the
flaming Battle of time
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the ambulances have like a fire
extinguisher or something not even four
or five feet away from a thank you
caroll of pitch this is definitely not
safe so it's not exactly a surprise that
some people gonna get hurt doing this I
don't know what they've been injured
with but we've seen a few ambulances I
don't know if that burns or if it's just
like a crush but hope people are all
right what was it like being backed out
it's pretty scary can see there's a big
like bigger fire how did you describe
being that close to the Tarbell's what
was extremely exciting as a thrill as a
rush I was hot the two is very warm I
didn't realize a how large the barrels
were and how much is flame äj-- we saw
I'd say most of what was happening and
then we'd walk away I said no we're
we're going to try and find the taxis
and you'd look behind you and it was
just there just assumed you'd see that
massive ball of fire and it's so good
things like this can happen in remote
areas of the UK because if it was any
closer or less health and safe to be all
over it'll be shut down and the
tradition in our innings is the 16th so
I think this might even predate guy
forks knives just been adopted thanks
Obama
[Music]
well anything I do in the vlog today is
gonna look tame by comparison a few
things to point out about last night I
don't know if they came across one Sally
you're watching this Sally was the lady
who put us up and gave us lots of food
and booze thank you very much they're
doing so Sally is a friend of the
cathedral so we knew her through sinking
basically and secondly what you saw were
tar barrels being carried right by
people
those are people from families that have
lived in the village or the town for
generations like it's a kind of a
privilege to be able to carry them and
the handover is it's not really a
peaceful thing apparently I couldn't see
but apparently it's more a wrestling to
try and take the bow off the other
person yeah nothing about this it was
normal nothing about last night was even
vaguely normal today though it's Billy
nice at the moment I had a lovely ready
meal for lunch that's the one that was
from breakfast
I've just been been I've eaten crap
today it's like I've been on a road trip
I've had like cookies and Doritos and
fruit and stuff like that so like I said
earlier in the week the objective for
this week is to finish off this chapter
and that's a rather important figure
that I've redone from from previous
never added these two columns though
it's basically extending work that I've
done before it's actually getting it
feels like I might be able to do this if
I do go over this week it's not gonna be
my much but I plan to do it's to stay
here until I get this chapter written
which means doing off the time I had
about five more figures and doing about
two or three pages of discussion so it's
very achievable in a day because all the
data sets were generated last night
because I thought ahead and now I've
just got to sort of take the slices out
and reuse other bits of code and get
some pretty looking Pickers so that's
what I'm gonna do
you
okay first section down horizontal
fluxes are done now it's your turn boy
or a year that's the good step
oh that's not good so that's it I down
to come home I just ate a very tempted
start work on a script breaching video
which might be out by now which is okay
to do if they want to and then I realize
I'm too tired and if I'm gonna get up at
7:30 some water go to work and click
this bloody chapter in the ground I need
some sleep I filled it with any kind of
social media presence it's tempting to
go attempting to be to become the
version of yourself that you perceive
others of the season UI button is done
and I think to a certain extent I've
become known as the guy who do you work
hard and all were working and never stop
and that's not true I definitely take
breaks too frequently and I do too many
projects that have trapped me in lots of
different ways and I I think it'd be
dangerous you need to try and work in
more than I can do because it would be
NIC damaging for mental health it be
damaging to my physical health and it
would negatively impact my work I think
I tell people that if you push too hard
you try and work hard and get less done
because you just exhausted though and so
that's why I didn't want to work as much
as I have five different videos I could
be working I don't know should be
miserable
I've got terrified self-care every night
again even if that just means going to
set up up-tempo stuff on the one day a
week I've got to take care myself
because I work so factor Sunday so as at
the time I'm recording I have about a
hundred and thirty pages in the pieces I
have a nearly complete without chapter I
had a half complete like in preparation
seconds without chapter conclusion will
be written
that and I've got about three weeks well
actually I have four week I actually
have more than perhaps I've sent myself
for week in order to I can't prove
anything
I've set myself four weeks to complete
my thesis and in that time I have
allocated well consider hand allocated I
never plan to do this without chapter
because it was mostly finished today but
one more day to finish your chapter two
weeks see the next one which mean the
next blog or hopefully we need putting
the finishing touches to either that
second result chapter or to my
conclusion and finishing my PhD thesis
thank you for watching guys like the
video if you enjoyed it subscribe
[Music]